all right come closer
every all right so I have an inward
spiral and I have an outward spiral I
have my shoulder ability to free my
shoulder uh will you put a hand on me so
sometimes it doesn't show up in my in
the G okay so I have a shoulder to free
and you can go back forward and back
forward and back okay and then the same
thing you have a qua the the qua can
free you feel that Chris right okay all
right
so I also as a marker I have a grid a
vertical grid on my
body there's two grids on my body well
one's a perimeter I have my outer rim
which is a Parker's concept and my uh
defense offense doesn't go outside my
shoulder line nor above the Arc of the
top of my head so it's like a egg shape
and then it comes down to the groin and
so all my defense offense and my hand
workk is in that area um but more
particularly I would ask you to think of
it as your elbows your elbows have to
stay in that area your hands can go out
of it but your elbows can't
okay then I have another grid made up of
vertical lines so one's on the shoulder
the outside side shoulder and then one
comes down the middle chest one down the
middle of my body and then you have the
same thing on the other
side
okay and
between my inward spiral and my outward
spiral my freeing shoulder both forward
and backwards and my qua forward and
backwards which includes inside and
outside you make up whatever
um spiral you need to generate whatever
effect you need on the UK you don't do
anything other than those things okay
and then whatever spiral I end up oping
oping for it is going to never have my
elbows go outside the outer
rim and my inward
spiral is going to take my elbow from
the y line on the outside that shoulder
line and bring it in
towards this midline here okay at least
to this half chest which is the yin line
it has to do that and then your outward
spiral has to do has to do the opposite
so it has to come from either the
midline or the yin line and it brings
your elbow back to that Y Line
okay all right with that
as he's here and I know that I in my
spiral I have gon and when I want to
change this that's when you would have
Chon okay there's
Chon and then you also would have um
doog so I can combine them in some very
strange
ways to get this to work work
okay obviously if I go get on right and
I move my body in and you can continue
the spiral and you get more out of this
as you move your body in out rotate in
or out Etc okay the one I want you to
feel right now is that first one so I'm
going to go in so my elbow's going to
start on the outside and come in
then I'm going to start the inward
spiral from here which is chew on you
see and I'm going to take it in the
jodon make it go over my
hand you can add your qua to
[Music]
it pay attention elbow out
in home
up okay let's try it
she goes over your head you go under her
arm without changing the arm pattern
hi where's your chew
done and bring your bring your claw up
launcher behind
you
no so here her elbow goes in then look
this is go you see if I keep
it so
in here then movement this
way okay don't don't smell the obvious
this is the point of this cuz it's a
weird one it's a weird one and you're
going to smell the obvious and want to
go this way and try to get them that way
but I'm going this
way this way and then she has to from
here from the Cheon I'm going to bring
her this way
okay
okay try
it okay so let's
look in in grappling if you want to
control someone's arm you have to
control the the wrist and the elbow just
control the wrist the elbow has too much
articulation that can bring it it's hard
to control control the wrist and the
shoulder and the same thing the elbow
can get out you have to control
both in your energetic you're
controlling bow from here that's
important as opposed to you're just here
in the wrist I never control his elbow
okay you have to control his elbow
so if you pay attention as my elbow is
moving along those grids and within
those rules you're controlling his elbow
so as my elbow moves my elbow goes from
the Yang line to the yin line and his
elbow went from the y y Yang line to the
yin line okay as my elbow passes into
Chon his elbows going around I'm
affecting his elbow okay and as my elbow
goes up his elbows Trav in that way in
space you should feel his
elbow as you're doing this maneuver you
should not be in his
hand trying to get this see you guys got
that so his elbow and of course you will
always feel the elbow if you are
connected if you if you seize his Center
then you will
always make the
elbow the articulation ability of the
elbow you'll make it null and void that
is why we don't just do linkage or
following all the time okay so as I move
his elbow goes in okay as my elbow rolls
under his goes up and I'm mov
back he's just staying still right now
now he's not pushing he's not pushing
he's not pushing and I get out of the
way cuz it looks totally different he's
just still in this throw and I'm doing
[Music]
everything moving his elbow and moving
it what happened something you got
here I'll do it again
what
happened what do you think happen you
went past the I did do you see so as I
moved his elbow here and I go like that
he's not going to go on that side his I
moved his elbow over
here if I do the same thing over here I
go this way and I go that way and not
going to get underneath cuz I'm still
moving elbow down if you wanted to do
that you could you better do
it but it's a choice I make so as I do
this it's very
small don't go too
far okay feel what you're doing if I go
too far I'll close it
off just far enough
gather the elbow into the
power okay see if you can start
shrinking it more blending it more okay
try okay if on that last one is I
brought my elbow in it brought his elbow
in okay on this one if I bring my elbow
down along the uh Y Line you see that
before I bring it in if you pay
attention watch his elbow I'm doing the
get hand work if I go in his elbow goes
in but if I take and keep my elbow along
the Yang line and do the inward spiral
his elbows going out you see that
there's his there's his young line and
this elbows outside of it
okay so outside his elbows
going you guys see that okay I'm going
show it standing up you'll get
more
that this way out and I add to that some
movement you get more
out without my arm actually taking my
elbow outside my shoulder
Line This Way turn I take a step you'll
get more outwardness
going but my elbow never goes outside my
shoulder line I'm never going like
this to do
that go
out turn step my hand comes straight my
Center here finish the
spiral you that elbow that went outside
starts to generate centrifugal energy
it's not that I
turn and turn
him my movements is
this I obey the
rules he'll go
out different can you see
that so if you look at my movement
that's my
rotation straight that's
it okay let's try that
position okay in ten
con you never step forward into
this
okay never go towards him
into the range of his weapon never go
into his R never go towards the other
side either that's said no no if you
have to you do but in IO they do it all
the time they
like but in real fighting that's stupid
okay in real fighting I never move to
his strong side you never move to the
strong side you might get caught yeah I
have to but I never do it out of out out
of intention okay so in SHO ten con you
stay away from that
side you stay away from
that remember here people do that
because that's where they do the they
gain the
momentum or you always move through
[Music]
watch out here one
pop you attention boom
add to the fall you don't actually have
to
do here hit turn his head because he's
already
falling
here I'm just going to turn his head
[Music]
try all I know everyone goes like
this you know talk
you're going to paint the circles I do a
big circle let go back I got to do the
whole okay
he's already he was already
falling you get it so I don't need to do
this makes no s
makes no martial
sense and he was already falling from
the angle
that so I'm not
going
here
here I'm not accelerating him he was
already being
accelerated what I am
doing is there's that energy is going
here like this
and then I'm going to take this and it
becomes a a
push so it's an inward
elbow boom boom it's in
elbow
okay so I would do this if you're
training I would try to do this
one and not do this so that I can can do
this okay and do it
in
so
externally that's what what you're doing
okay and you get X energy out of that
okay but what's my what are my hands
doing in terms of
elevation either
dropping so that tells you what's the
chi doing dropping the Chi's dropping
okay and so this this hand that comes
here oh is very very heavy it's not
looking over here to do this kind of
stuff
okay so as I come
around very very heavy okay more like ma
hand what it should feel like okay so
you have to let that Che drop
that way he's off
balance cuz he he's almost about to fall
right you could get him to fall there
but sh and that's where we're
going is a technique when someone was
about to fall and then did not fall
that's where that's where the opening of
sha is
okay so if you and we're going to do one
more progression before we get to the
technique but if you pay
attention as he tries to get his
balance you see he did not fall there's
the Tilt for Shon right
here it's more his job it's not me
going because I would be taking them out
of check pay attention
he not in check he starts to go he's not
in
check
okay we don't want to do that all right
so here we'll get there here's the next
progression okay so he would
be more out
here right he's outside of my Yin Yong
lung and his energies go on that way
right okay so as I do that
same spiral that we had before we're
going to take him
backwards okay cuz we're not in the same
place you see that but I do the same
movement
things are different don't move this in
don't move your elbow in okay this goes
this
way okay this
way pay attention to where he is it
changes what we're doing
you can add your CLA to this whole
thing okay but he's going that way even
though I'm doing something that
originally brought him this way and went
me under it okay so let's
try Okay so he's off
there I don't want to bring my
my elbow this way or my chew on that way
yes that's true okay but I also don't
want
to physically paint what I'm seeing him
do okay so I don't want to
go like
that my my hand does
this my hand does
this okay
such that if he was
here you see when my hand goes this way
he goes that
way my hand looks exactly the same hand
looks exactly the
same just like when he drive don't paint
with your hands what you're seeing his
body
do that's not what we're doing I have
these rules to follow because those
rules take my outer deltoid out of it
and keep my hands in the offensive
defensive Readiness okay so same
thing don't paint
it the angle that you have generated is
enough okay say enough
uh people
watching it's not that he pushes and I
just kind of lift it up and he goes
flying out that way that's not what's
happening he's not pushing at all you're
Gathering it in the same way that we did
that other
day also I'm not doing the external
thing that chba does when he comes here
and he gets a kind of n going there and
you make your guy come around but he has
to do acrobatics to not fall
there you go this
way
okay that lock works all the more better
if you're doing the same thing that I'm
doing here that the lock that you have
is going to break more of his body and
make him around more
okay it's going to be more painful but
it's not necessary okay so don't paint
the
picture just do the arm
pattern W
boom okay that's
enough okay try it again don't paint the
pattern okay back so as he's going that
way feeling that
momentum he's going around that way if I
do that hand work it it should keep
accelerating okay going around this way
and it goes this way around
me
boom I keep him going
now don't stop him
[Music]
keep them going
now okay try in that little drill all
we're working on is on the the
transference of that man going still
going behind me still going around but
he's going up like my hands are going up
but he's actually going that way okay
but if you pay attention in the
technique youd have his balance and then
you brought them back out of balance and
we're not going to do that what we do
instead in the technique is I drop
underneath all of that okay so as he got
is that loop I dropped underneath
don't let him come
up so you pay
attention just
dropping I'm not pulling him in other
words I'm not going here he's
up and then I go
down what's happening is as he's coming
around his energy is going there
that's that's what I'm
doing little extra
acceleration
Bo so watch how my knees are already
dropping we're going to do the last
drill not going to hold him
Cool
D send him
around try that progression hey so as
we're moving all my duck under here and
I just staying with his
hand I'm not pulling him down he was
already falling I'm not pulling him down
I'm staying with his
okay this this part was already making
him lose his balance now all I have to
do is stay with his
hand okay and you might have to turn you
might have to slow your
we but the hand has to fall back
down according to that
grip okay so what I mean by that is is
you're going to pin this
shoulder okay and so that hand should be
underneath that midline of the grid then
then it has your weight okay and that's
where your strike is on that same line
you
hear now over here I don't do this
version this is CH sense this is just
too weak for me
around
the there's the line right here that's
where I push down straight and then
there's your
strike
straight here it is again you see
there's a slight turn in my body so he
falls under my
nose right here that's that Center Line
and there's the power
line okay try it and not everyone but
The Usual Suspects here right okay as
you're coming around here you bring him
out of posture you stop accelerating him
and then you're going to use power to
take him
down uh first of all I can't he's
already stronger than me I can't even if
I drop my whole way I can't pull him
down he's in perfect posture which he's
going to be
he wasn't then you go perfect posture
right here I'm not going to pull him not
going to pull him down it's not going to
happen Okay and in the time that I tried
to break his shoulder he already came in
with whatever right F no okay it's
stupid you just have to keep him
accelerating as you bring him this way
never stop the technique don't take him
out of position
okay then the next one is is you're
making them go all the way around you
can you see no you stay with the hand
you already did all you could with the
Hand by and ab Bain the rules that I
have you see now if I go like
this I broke those grid
rules and he's up way too long
so you have to obey the grid rules while
you move with a small turn you see this
is a small turn I stay with the hands so
we'll go
slower we have to gain the kazushi cuz
he he can't be falling okay so he's
going back and I turn you see this a
small
turn not he goes all the way around me
cuz he'd be standing and now I use
power how do you know where to turn
you'll feel the y space all you go turn
to not stretch your grip
okay okay so uh if I'm going to do a uh
single leg right if I'm if I'm going to
come up and and do this
draw it's not the
case that I come here and then draw see
but it's also not the case that I'm here
leaning I keep the posture you see and I
lower the
posture that's the same thing here
it's not that I am upright cuz if I'm
upright he's upright and then I try to
overpower and that's not going to
work but it's also not like I
here I keep the
posture keep the
posture boom but if you pay attention
I'm dropping
because I don't want his
shoulder to come back
up his shoulder is telling me how low I
have to go my head has to go under his
shoulders I don't lift his shoulder up
over my head that would take him out of
chest TR